Republican senator Lindsey Graham has
become very comfortable in the
right-wing propaganda bubble where
you're just allowed to kind of say
really whatever you want and it's not
really challenged in any way and he was
very triggered when he appeared on CNN
and Dana Bash quite honestly very gently
pushed back against like one little tiny
corner of what he was saying about
abortion and he didn't like it one bit
he didn't like being questioned in any
way and attacked her saying you're
covering for these people there's
actually some really interesting data
underlying what they're talking about
about abortion so let's listen to it
let's look at it then I'll talk to you
more I think the Republican party will
be in good standing to oppose late term
abortion like most of the Civilized
world
guys what no no no your media you keep
covering for these guys they introduce
legislation that allowed abortion On
Demand with taxpayer-funded uh were you
paying for it the taxpayer up to the
bone of birth that was their position in
Washington That's the Law they want to
pass and nobody in your business will
talk about it it's far better Senator uh
I'm not covering for anybody and you
know that and when I have Democrats on
and I've had Democrats I've asked for
the facts I have asked many all of them
about their position on where uh where
they believe this issue should be okay
The Temper Tantrum by Lindsey Graham
accusing Dana Bash of covering for them
just because she inserted one little
measly fact into the discussion that is
a result of the propaganda bubble that
the Republican party is so used to
uh it's really important to understand
two parts of this first of all Dana Bash
is correct the Supreme Court decision in
1973 in Roe v Wade established that a
woman has a constitutional right to
terminate a pregnancy up to the point of
fetal viability which is generally
around 24 weeks of gestation
since Roe v Wade
with medical advances there have been
very limited
instances where a fetus was able to
survive a week or two earlier than that
insanely rare insanely risky but what we
are talking about here indeed with Roe v
Wade which is gone now okay but Dana
Bash is correct this isn't controversial
Roe v Wade dealt with the point of
viability generally considered 24 weeks
but there's another really important
thing to understand
abortions in general after 21 weeks
forget about 24 after 21 weeks are
really rare
difficult to get
costly time intensive and only even
performed by some providers now it
doesn't matter what you think is right
or wrong the point is something that
barely happens gets almost all of the
attention and the vast majority of
abortions get almost no attention
there's a very good graphic from the CDC
which we're going to put up on the
screen which shows that more than a
third of abortions are before six weeks
remember it usually takes five weeks to
even know you're pregnant
34 of abortions are before six weeks a
full 52 percent of abortions are before
seven weeks and then you you stack up
the numbers 99 of abortions are before
19 weeks and when you look out at this
graph and you look all the way out to 29
weeks
0.01 of abortions are happening at that
point and if you go beyond 19 Beyond 29
weeks it is statistically zero so
Lindsay is upset that Dana Bash
said oh Roe v Wade dealt with up until
the point of viability
what she should have said is Lindsay 91
of abortions happen before 13 weeks 99
of abortions happened before 19 weeks or
some formulation of that based on the
CDC data uh but they don't care they
don't want to talk about that and
instead they want to talk about
two days before the due date a week
after the due date and all of these
different things now let's divide that
up into two parts just so we're being
thorough
the after-birth abortions
I still am not totally sure where that
comes from it's it's not anywhere there
was a rumor from New York that they
started it was untrue there was a rumor
from Virginia they started it was untrue
so after birth abortion it's not even
worthy of our discussion the day before
the due date abortion
really
precise
statements about this were made in some
abortion hearings I want to say it was
about a year ago maybe a year and a half
ago and OB gyns and other medical
practitioners testified under oath about
this and they said listen just because
it might be legal somewhere to have an
abortion in the third trimester doesn't
mean that obese are just going to do it
and that it doesn't mean that people are
coming to us asking for that and
multiple OB GYN said it's never even
come up in my practice this scenario of
you're 37 weeks pregnant and you say hey
you know what
I think I just don't want a baby oh sure
we'll perform an abortion
most OBS have said it's not even come up
the rare cases where that happens you're
talking about the mother's life being at
risk
and that it is just not a thing the way
that Republicans pretend that it is so
anyway Lindsay's all triggered because
one little fact was interjected I wish
Dana Bash had actually said more and
said why do you and your ilk insist on
focusing on a part of the curve that is
below
0.01 of all abortions which has been
widely discussed by OBS and we Now
understand the truth of it why do you
pretend like that's what abortion is but
she didn't do that
and fine she didn't think it was her
place to but Lindsay Lindsay's got to
settle down and get out of that
propaganda bubble a little more often